مساء الخير في تطورات خطيره ومثيره للدهشه
والحياه في البحر الاحمر
التطورات دي ممكن تكشف لنا بوضوح ودقه عن
مدى التغيير اللي حادث او اللي بيجري في
موازين القوى في العالم وبالتالي ان
عكستها على المنطقه العربيه ومنطقه الشرق
الاوسط
لكن قبل ما اقول لحضراتكم ايه هي تطورات
تتخيل الاول منطقه البحر الاحمر
وافضل من التخيل انك تفتح كده اكتب خريطه
البحر الاحمر علشان تكتشف انه هذا المجرى
المائي المهمه منذ فجر التاريخ
يمتد من الشمال الى الجنوب بطول حوالي
1900 كيلو تقريبا اعرضوا في اقصد اقصد س ا
على ثلاث مائه كيلومتر
الدول المطله على البحر الاحمر الثمانيه
لو اخذنا هم من الجنوب الى الشمال
جيبوتي اه اه بريا السودان مصر وبعدين في
الساعه على الساحل الافريقي تشوب الساحل
الاشياء والتلاقي اسرائيل الاردن السعوديه
اليمن
والبحر بينتهي او يربطوا بالمحيط الهندي
ما يسمى ب باب مضيق باب المندب الشهير جدا
وهذا المضيق بيفصل البحر بيربط البحر
بالمحيط الهندي ومكونات او مكونات وخلق
عدم وبحر العرب والخليج العربي في بدايه
مهمه عشان نتخيل مدى اهميه هذا البحر
الكبيره جدا اللي بيحصل مشرق العالم
هي التطورات اللي مثيره للخيال وخطيره جدا
ان تحاول تتخيل على الاخبار اللي انت
سمعتها على مدار الشهور
او السنوات القليله الماضيه
قبليها عند كل اخذناها اهم الاحداث اللي
من الشمال للجنوب تلاقي عند حضرتك مشروع
السعوديه العملاق الذي يسمى
يوم بالعربي يعني المستقبل الجديد وتلاقي
قبل هذا المشروع سابقوا او تم التمهيد
اليه ب اه امور مهمه هي ترسيم الحدود ما
بين السعوديه او مصر وفي مياه البحر
الاحمر
وتلا ذلك او تابع ذلك انتقال السي انتقال
تيران وصنافير
جزيرتي تيران وصنافير
من السياده المصريه الى السياده السعوديه
وتلى ذلك وهو ما يجري الان محاولات لدول
هذه المنطقه بقياده مصر والسعوديه على
تاسيس تحالف يضم دول البحر الاحمر
السبعه واسرائيل دون ان تذكر سرا كده خارج
الكواليس ويمكن كمان بيحولوا اليها
الصومال اللي هي ب تطل على خليج عدن وحدث
هذا التحالف اللي ممكن نتكلم عنه فيما بعد
هو حمايه امن البحر الاحمر والدول
المتشاطئه عليه ينزل تحت شويه لانه عندنا
وصراع وخلاف نتيجه محاولات التركيه
السيطره على جزيره سواكن السودانيه ان
ينزل شويه نلاقي انه ما بين السودان وما
بين مصر او بطول البحر الاحمر تعزيزات غير
مسبوقه من البحريه المصريه اللي بدا تتخصص
اسطول مصر كان عندها اسطول واحد ما بين
البحرين الاحمر والمتوسط اصبح الان عندها
اسطول ان والاسطول الجنوبي اللي احنا بصدد
الكلام عنه قوامه هو الناقله الطائرات ال
جمال عبد الناصر بنجد تعزيزات اخرى موجوده
مصريه بطول مجرى النهر سواء في اه الدول
الصديقه لها زي اريتريا او سيتي و كلام
كثير يقال عن جهود مصر في جزيره فرسان
السعوديه
علامات استفهام على خطه او النوايا
المصريه من تعزيز وجودها في هذه الجزيره
في جنوب البحر الاحمر وهلا قعدنا ايضا
حركه كثيره جدا وكبيره جدا على ما يعني
البحر كلها خصوصا في موانئ ال القرن
الافريقي اللي هي اريتريا الصومال جهوده
طيب كمان عندنا التغيرات الاكبر فيه او
المثيره الاكثر اثاره شاهو ما يجري في
جيبوتي جيبوتي اصبحت الخط او مركز قواعد
عسكريه لدول من مختلف لدول اقليميه
وعالميه مختلفه كلها ب تتكرر في منطقه
صغيره
كل دوله عندها اه قاعده عسكريه بالنسبه
للولايات المتحده عندها اكثر من قاعده
عسكريه تدور فيها معنيين مع الصين مع
اليابان مع
ايطاليا مع فرنسا اضيف الى هذه الدول دول
اخرى قادمه في الطريق زي السعوديه طبعا
الصين واليابان دول اول قاعدتين عسكريتين
لهم يعني اه خارج حدودهم و ب بالنسبه
لليابان بعد الحرب العالميه الثانيه لانه
قبل الحرب العالميه الثانيه ذكر عندها
القواعد العسكريه في اماكن اخرى عندنا
السعوديه بتبني قاعده عسكريه هناك وتركيا
بتحاول والروس تقدمت بطلب ولم يوافق عليه
حتى الان والدول الاخرى زي الهند بتحاول
وقد تنجح والده بيقول لنا ان في عمليه
سباق تسلح كبير جدا في البحر الاحمر
وبالاضافه الى سباق محموم على استغلال او
محاولات استغلال الثروات البحريه اللي
موجوده او على الاقل تامين المصالح من
خلال
الحصول على امتيازات او تطوير الموانئ
المدنيه المواقف البحريه التجاريه
العراقيه السبب في كل اللي فيها كل موضوع
من دول يستحق منا
وثلاثه لكن مجرد رؤوس اقلام ان ما نقدر
نقول ان الاطار العام اللي انا معني به في
الحاله دي ممكن نفسر كل التغيرات
لسببين رئيسيين السبب الاول ان ي اللي
احنا كنا تكلمنا عنه في حال
محاوله فهمه العالم وفهم العالم في عشرين
دقيقه اللي هو التغير في موازين القوى في
العالم الحاصل عندنا امرين تراجع في
النفوذ الامريكي وفي المقابل صعود قوى
اخرى التراجع في النفوذ الامريكي ادى الى
اه يعني بعض هذه التطورات وصعود القوى
الاخرى لدى بعض التطورات الاخرى يعني
الصعود الصيني والروسي
والتراجع الامريكي يفسر لنا كثير من
الاحداث الموجودين تعالى ناخذ الاول
التراجع الامريكي
ذكر كده من في التسعينات يعني بعد سقوط
الاتحاد السوفياتي كان البحر الاحمر
وباب المندب و اه الخليج وخليج عدن والبحر
العربي ال ال تقريبا نسي وخليج عدم كل ده
او الخليج العربيه والخليج عدم هو الذي في
بقيه الممرات المائيه في العالم كانت ملكا
للولايات المتحده اللي هي وحلفائها ب
سيطره سيطره ليست محل نزاع يذكر من جانب
اي قوه اخرى وبالتالي السيطره الامريكيه
دي كانت محليه الامور هادئه تماما
وكل اللي ممكن تسمعه في البحر الاحمر حتى
اما السفر وهي بتاخر مياه ذهابا وايابا
اوروبا واسيا في اقصى درجات الاضطرابات
والفوضى بعض الطلقات الطائشه من ال القرار
سنه ظاهره القرصنه لما كانت موجوده في
التسعينات وفي الالفين واستمرت لها كم سنه
قبل ان يتم السيطره عليها
لما حصل التغير الجديد في القصه ان
الولايات المتحده
تتراجع على الارض ومش بس التراجع على
الارض لك ما نبت نوايا معلنه بتقول انا
غير راغبه في الوجود في المنطقه
والكلام دلاله واضحه الاعلان وان لم يتم
حتى الان هو المح اعلانها على الانسحاب من
سوريا و
مفاوضاتها مع طالبان للخروج من
الخروج من افغانستان بعد سبعطاشر سنه من
حرب لم تثمر او لم تسفر لها النتيجه تذكر
امريكا بتحاول تتراجع وتخفف من وجودها وهي
بتقول والامريكان بيقولوا زي ما قلت لك ما
قبل كده في حلقه ثانيه احنا مش قادرين
يمول هذه النفقات الامبراطوريه وفي
تقديرات امريكيه بيقولوا ان احنا من 2011
اسف من الفين وواحد والى الان الامريكان
متورطين في حروب لا تنتهي واشتباكات
رئيسيه و جانبيه
خسائرها كالتالي
سبعه الاف جندي قتيل اكثر من ستين الف
جريح سبعه مليون خسائر الارقام محل نظر
ممكن يتناقش فيها لكن ما لا يمكن ان
نتناقش فيه هو رغبه الامريكان يجلس الان
في ولايه من ايام وبامان عاوز يخرج من
المنطقه ويخفف وجود لها على شان وده تقطع
كلها العدوين الرئيسيين الصين وروسيا دول
هما اللي بس تدعو انتباهه وعاوز من الموقع
عشان يعرف ايه اللي بيحصل في البحار
الشرقيه وفي هذا العالم الخصوم الرئيسيين
لما ان هو عاوز ي يعني يخفف قواته يعني
اصبح ال بوجود والهيمنه الامريكيه اللي
كانت تكفل هذا الهدوء شبه تام بدون اي
مشاكل يعني تذكر اصبح الدول الاخرى
الاقليميه تبحث عن بدائل
للوجود الامريكي في اطار هذه البدائل تقدر
تفهم حاجات كثير اول حاجه ممكن تفهمها
حياه او التحالف الجاري انشاؤه الان باسم
مستقل اسمه لكن استقروا على مقره في جده
تحالف دول البحر الاحمر واللي ممكن يضم
معها كمان الصومال التي لا تطل على البحر
الاحمر طيب هدف التحالف هدف التحالف حمايه
امن البحر الاحمر الدول المتشاطئه على
البحر الاحمر حمايه ال ال مصالح هذه الدول
وتحديدا المملكه العربيه السعوديه التي
تستشعر قلقا شديدا من ايران ما كان يمكن
ان يكون موجود في التسعينات حين كانت
الولايات المتحده تسيطر برم برا وجوا على
كل المجريات المياه او الممرات المهمه لا
اظن التحالف ده هو الثالث من نوعه المرادي
هو تحالف دول البحر الاحمر لكن سابقه سابق
ومحاوله التحالف الاسلامي لم واضحه ايران
في اليمن
اللي بتطلع على البحر الاحمر اللي بتطلع
على مضيق باب المندب اللي يشرف على مرور
معظم تداولت المملكه العربيه السعوديه
ودول الخليج من النفط في حوالي اثنين
مليار برميل نفط في عنده من البحر الاحمر
سنويا
مشروع القوى العربيه التي تقدمت بمصرف
2015 وكلها مجموعه من التحالف انت تحاول
تامن يعني
السعوديه ودول الخليج بتحاول تجد لها
بدائل عن الوجود الامريكي اللي بتخفف او
العوده تخفف من اعماق حمايه دول الخليج لا
يفسر لي ايه التراجع الامريكي يفسر لنا
محاولات ترقيه انها تيجي منطقه القرن
الافريقي للسودان الان وتركيا هي صحيح
حليف
الحليف في الحلف عضو في الحلف الاطلسي
والمفروض انها حليف للولايات
لكن الخلافات بتصاعد طول الوقت وهي بتحلم
من الفين واثنين وكلها وجود في البحر
الاحمر لما ابدت الولايات المتحده تتراجع
تركيا زيها زي باقي وحلفاء الولايات
المتحده عاوزه تعزز وتحافظ على مصالحها
بنفسها فاجات الى السودان و بتحاول انه هي
اه تنشا قاعده عسكريه في الصومال انتهت
بالفعل قاعده عسكريه في الصومال اكثر من
كل ده يعزز لنا او يفسر لنا
التحالف الخفي يعني ثلاثه تحالفات حول
التعامل هم السعوديه القوى العربيه القوى
الاسلاميه
التحالف دول البحر الاحمر بالاضافه الى
تحالف اخر مهم ولكنه خفي وهو التحالف مع
اسرائيل بحيث تكون اسرائيل اذا كانت
الولايات المتحده متردده في جهود والدفاع
عن حلفائها السابقين وحلفائها السابقين
بيحاولوا تحالفوا مع حليف موجود في
المنطقه وهو اسرائيل ضد اخطار مختلفه
ويستعين قدراتها العسكريه الكبيره و تزال
بقدرتها الاقتصاديه الكبيره سواء في يوم
او في غير يوم وفي مواجهه الخطر الايراني
او اي اخطار اخرى تعتقد الدول المنطقه
انها م تعرضه لهم العنصر الاول ان عنصر
ادهم اما عنصر صعود القوى الاخرى وتحديدا
الصين ثم روسيا يفسر لنا ايضا احداث كثير
يعني امريكا تشعر بالقلق من الصين من
الصعود الصيني الكبير كانت تتمنى ان هي
تخفف من وجودها في الشرق الاوسط عشان تشوف
اللي بيحصل في المناطق الاخرى في شرق اسيا
وتحديدا في بحر الصين الجنوبي اللي بدات
توسع في الصين على حساب النفوذ الامريكي
لكن فجاه ان الصين مش بس بتعزيز وجودها
وتقني جزر صناعيه تزوج قوتها ونفوذها في
بحر الصين الجنوبي اكثر من كده جاءت وبنت
اول قاعده عسكريه خارج اراضيها في منطقه
جيبوتي على بعد 10 كيلو متر من قاعده
عسكريه ضخمه
لايات المتحده على نفس الاراضي والصين
بتعمل كده ليه لانه زي ما التاريخ يعلم
نفوذ صعود اقتصادي نفوذ سياسي لازم يترجم
وقوع عسكريه وخاصه الاساطيل علشان تحمي
هذه التجاره الكبيره هذا الوجود الصيني هي
تزايد الصين اصبحت انظر مسندم وانظر
مستثمر لافريقيا وبالتالي سوف يتزايد في
هذه المنطقه وفي غيرها اشكركم ان اعربت
النهار ده مشهد يعني الصوره بين الروم هي
اللي بيحصل في منطقه البحر الاحمر اذا كان
حضراتكم مهتمين باي من هذه الموضوعات سواء
مشروع يوم الاتحاد او التحالف الجديد
لحمايه دول دور من شاطئ البحر الاحمر
يحصل فيه
بالنسبه للاسطول المصري التحالف المتزايد
مع اسرائيل استاذنك ما كتب ولى وان شاء
الله نخصص لها حلقه قادمه باذن الله الى
اللقاء
[موسيقى]